welcome to the field the world of the
most Advanced Technologies where you can
witness the operation of gigantic
agricultural machines some Farmers have
been experimenting with the parsley
Harvester developed by MCO in
agricultural company from North Brent in
the Netherlands one of the standout
features of this machine is its ability
to cleanly cut off any remaining leaves
allowing the plants to regenerate
quickly and optimizing their growth
cycle after harvest The Parsley
Harvester is equipped with sharp cutting
blades as the machine moves through the
parsley rows the blades cut the parsley
at a predetermined height after the
parsley is cut it is either conveyed
upward by a belt or vacuums through a
tube using a vacuum system this system
operates like a high-powered vacuum
cleaner sucking The Parsley into a
collection area at the rear of the
machine this giant machine is commonly
used in herb crop farming regions
particularly in the Netherlands or other
European countries with a width of 6.5 M
it can Harvest dozens of tons of herbs
each day this significantly increases
output when compared to other manual
methods ensuring uniform cutting and
reducing the need for labor as a result
it helps Farmers to save costs and
increase profits the soil tiller is an
advanced agricultural device that
enhances the efficiency of soil
preparation for crops with its deep soil
processing capability this machine
breaks up the stubborn clumps of soil
making the soil loose and easy to form
into Row the tilled soil becomes
suitable for sewing and creates better
conditions for plant growth the tiller
also helps form loose mounds of soil
which serve as a stable foundation for
the growth of root crops this allows the
roots to grow without disruption or
interference from hard soil furthermore
the machine features a modular design
offering multiple Technical Solutions to
suit different farming conditions with
large wheels that roll easily on moist
ground and the ability to work at a
depth of up to 10 in the tiller can
handle six crop rows at once
farmers can easily install and replace
the tiller's components the machine
system is also designed to be erosion
resistant helping to protect the soil
environment one of the standout features
of the soil tiller is its
flexibility allowing the working width
to be adjusted with a few simple manual
operations additionally farmers can
combine it with a planting machine
enabling both tilling and sewing to be
done in a single pass saving time and
effort farmers use peanut Harvesters to
save labor and effectively reduce work
intensity tasks that would normally take
several days or even weeks with manual
labor can now be completed in just a few
hours to too begin the Harvest farmers
use a peanut Digger that moves through
each row it's equipped with a blade to
cut the roots from the underside of the
plants rotating time on the machine dig
deep into the soil flipping the plants
over so that they are laid out in rows
on the ground with the peanut pods
facing one side the Harvester then
passes through quickly removing the
peenuts to the rear using rollers
preventing them from sinking into the
soil a vibrating C is designed to remove
impurities as the peanuts are gathered
into the machine the peanut Harvester
can operate smoothly even in wet Fields
adapting to various field conditions the
peanut Harvester combines digging
lifting and flipping into a seamless
process additionally picking efficiency
reaches
98% which saves considerable time labor
and energy most commercial Harvesters
use either spindle or Vine shaking
mechanisms to remove the fruit from the
vine the primary impact comes from a
flexible horizont onal double rod that
strikes the canopy and shakes it to
release the grapes in some regions
machine harvesting can reduce labor
costs by up to
75% these machines move through the vine
rows shaking The Vines so that the
grapes fall onto a conveyor belt after
being collected impurities are removed
through a series of screens the
Harvester grapes are immediately
transferred to trucks for Trans port to
the processing facility this method of
machine harvesting is exclusively used
for wine grape production it is
estimated that a machine can Harvest 1
hectare in around 5 hours Harvesters can
also run continuously for 24 hours a day
machine harvesting is typically more
cost effective and well suited for large
Vineyards located on flat terrain with
machine harvesting grapes can be chilled
faster than with handpicking these
machines are equipped with lights to
assist in nighttime harvesting helping
Farmers to shorten the harvesting period
especially during peak times grapes that
are left on The Vines for too long after
ripening will quickly deteriorate and
perish these massive machines can
collect up to 300 kg of produce in just
a few minutes significantly reducing
labor and harvest time while providing
flexibility to meet the demands of
modern agriculture this tarp system can
extend from 9 M to 11 M and is
automatically operated to optimize
harvesting processes it is commonly used
to harvest fruits such as olives almonds
cherries and oranges the Shaker is
capable of adjusting the shaking
sequence to effectively detach all the
fruit thanks to its easy to operate
design the the operator can use this
equipment in any intensive farming
system the Harvester is equipped with an
automatic ground tarp rolling system
increasing the Harvest speed by up to
75% of the fruit on the tree the cabin
is integrated with a 7in color screen to
control the entire machine along with an
automatic brightness adjusting camera
system this Machinery ensures continuous
and efficient harvesting the automatic
transplanter operates in the field with
the modern and highly efficient planting
process to operate the machine Farmers
must first prepare the soil to ensure
proper moisture and looseness seedling
trays are then loaded into the machine
the transplanter is Compact and easy to
use operators can precisely set
parameters such as the distance between
plants and the planting depth during
operation ation the machine uses a
mechanical or hydraulic system to lift
each seedling from the tray and plant it
into the soil the robotic arms move
rhythmically ensuring each seedling is
planted in the correct position when the
temperature is cooler and the fruit is
less likely to get damaged farmers use a
pole with a net to pick the mangoes
ensuring that they don't fall and Bruise
they leave a bit of stem on the fruit
which helps it to stay fresh for longer
mango trees can grow between 30 to 40 ft
tall making harvesting tricky farmers
use ladders or equipment to reach the
fruit at the very top of the tree each
mango is picked by hand and placed in
Trace all the harvested mangoes are kept
in the shade under trees while waiting
for transport next Farmers load mangoes
onto trucks and take them to the packing
area at the packing facility mangoes are
cooled to remove field heat and lower
their temperature to the desired level
helping to extend their shelf life
sorting is done using various tools like
mango grading machines categorize the
fruit by size and other color sensors
that measure ripeness packing and
transporting the mangoes are critical
stages requiring careful handling to
avoid reducing the fruit's market value
stored at a temperature of 9 to 10째 C
mangoes can maintain their quality for
up to 21 days mangoes are a rich source
of vitamins minerals antioxidants and
fiber this valuable fruit is widely
exported to International markets giving
Farmers the chance to tap into the
global trade opportunities in 2023
Global grape production reached 28.4 m
million tons with China and the US
leading the world California is famous
for its wine and the excitement that
comes with harvest season the warm
Autumn months bring ideal weather for
grape harvesting by August the grapes
begin to ripen the most noticeable sign
is the color change across the vineyard
green grapes turn yellow sometimes even
red while red grapes shift to a deep
purple at this stage The Grapes also
increase in size and become softer grape
Harvest typically begins 30 to 70 days
after the fruit is set during this
period we see an increase in sugar
content and a decrease in acidity within
the fruit harvesting begins early in the
morning with workers picking row by row
most wine grapes are best harvested
around 22 to 24 bricks hand picking can
often yield better results skilled
workers carefully cut each cluster and
place them into containers while
removing any sunburned or rotten grapes
Vineyards that opt for hand picking
usually priori as quality over quantity
at the winery the grapes are separated
from the stems and leaves to prevent any
bitterness during
fermentation next comes the crushing
process using the mechanical presses the
grapes are then left to rest and
fermentation begins within 6 to 12 hours
converting all the sugar into alcohol in
regions with particularly hot climates
Farmers often Harvest grapes at night in
the cooler conditions Pickers can ensure
that all the grapes are at the same
temperature wine makers in warmer areas
typically pick grapes at night to
preserve their Aroma and prevent
spontaneous fermentation high quality
grapes harvested this way lead to better
wine lower energy costs and higher
efficiency Farmers start sewing eggplant
seeds indoors around 10 weeks before the
last frost date the seedlings will grow
when the soil temperature reaches 60째 F
Farmers plant them with a maximum
spacing of 24 in between plants and 2 to
3 ft between rows eggplants thrive in
nutrient rich well- drained soil
mulching can help eggplants grow strong
in the spring adding bright colored
straw mulch in the summer helps to
reduce heat buildup eggplants prefer
soil with a pH of 6.5 and need one to 2
in of water each week eggplants can be
harvested around 70 days after sewing
they can quickly become overripe and
bitter so check them every 1 to 2 days
to see if they're ready overall the best
time to harvest eggplants is from
Midsummer onwards around July to
September when the skin of the eggplant
is shiny and smooth they are ready for
Harvest Farmers cut a section of the
fruit stem it's important to handle the
eggplants gently during Harvest as they
can be easily bruised careful selection
is crucial to ensure that only the best
eggplants move on to the next stage once
the baskets are full workers transport
them to the Sorting area here the
eggplants are carefully arranged and
sorted harvesting eggplants can take
several days to a few weeks and regular
harvesting helps increase yield like
cucumbers eggplants are very sensitive
to temperature when temperatures drop
below 50째 Fahrenheit it can damage their
texture and flavor eggplants can
typically be stored for 1 to 2 weeks
after harvest as long as they are kept
properly at processing facilities
eggplants are turned into delicious
products they are cut into bite-sized
pieces seasoned fried and combined with
sauces to create rich flavors watermelon
Vines spread 6 to 8 ft within 30 days
after 2 months the first watermelons
will appear finally the crop is ready
for Harvest within around 3 months due
to varying pollination times not all
watermelons ripen at the same time as a
result Farmers often need to harvest the
same field multiple times one team of
workers goes ahead to cut the
Watermelons from The Vines then turns
them over to indicate that they are
ready a second team of workers then
collects the cut watermelons from behind
they form a watermelon conveyor line and
load the melons onto trucks for packing
Farmers must be extremely careful not to
scratch or damage the fruit to avoid
skin abrasions and rot harvesting is
done only in dry weather after
harvesting Farmers place the Watermelons
with the bottom side down to prevent
sunburn they are carefully placed in
trucks lined with soft fabric and dry
grass or straw at the bottom temperature
control between 10 to 16째 C helps keep
the watermelons in the best conditions
and extends their shelf life sugarcane
farming provides over 19,000 jobs and
nearly $4.7 billion annually to the
economy in southeast Asian countries
sugar cane is grown by local farmers on
small plots of land and harvested using
traditional methods farmers use hand
knives or cutting blades for manual
harvesting this requires skilled labor
improper harvesting can lead to a
reduced sugar yield and problems during
the Milling process typically farmers
will harvest a crop every 3 to 5 years
after harvesting the sugar cane is
bundled together the farmers then
transport the bundles to the train once
the train is fully loaded it departs for
the sugar processing plant sugar cane is
chopped into smaller pieces before being
crushed then put in large roller mills
to extract the juice the juice is
processed to remove impurities through
coagulation and
sedimentation this process produces raw
sugar by separating sugar crystals from
the surrounding Molasses for every 100
tons of sugar cane produced about 12
tons of sugar are produced however most
of the sugar is produced from from
mechanical harvesting about 50% of the
sugar cane in the US comes from Florida
the Florida sugar industry has an annual
income of over $800 million with a total
economic value of over 2
billion mature sugar cane can grow up to
10 ft tall farmers use mechanical
Harvesters to collect the cane from
September until January mechanical
harvesting reduces the average
harvesting time from 32 hours to just 6
to 12 this increased efficiency leads to
higher yields and greater profits for
Farms